our speaker today is Reverend Michael
bird who is the rector of Christchurch
bronxville he is on the Diocese of New
York's Commission on ministry
identifying young talent helping them to
turn their past the ministry he's also
an adjunct professor of pastoral
theology general Seminary in New York
but here's my anecdote in nineteen the
1990s I was a much younger man and a
youth minister at st. church that I
served now a new canaan and there was an
amazing youth minister dentistry at st.
marks I mean killer youth minister who
in addition everything else talk about a
secret weapon also coach the girls
lacrosse team so he had the high school
talk about evangelism he just on the
high school and roamed the youth
ministry st. marks and he went on to
fail or in other places including a
Christchurch bronxville and when we came
to do the colloquium with the in Britain
we need to find eight exemplary youth
ministries and Tony said I don't think
you're going to find eight exemplary
youth ministries to use for the case
study system I just said if we find
Michael bird we got one and we just went
out to the world that googled until we
found him and sure enough killer great
youth ministry at Bronx or and what was
so distinctive about his presentation
was the extraordinarily creative ways in
which he had created a pilgrimage of a
year that nurtured spiritual habits and
covenant of life amongst the members of
the really deep in rich experience so of
course we've been looking forward to an
opportunity to welcome to the series
Michael thanks
of all the strange and wonderful
coincidences for skip to share the
anecdote and me coaching girls lacrosse
and to have the parent of one of my
former girls lacrosse players in the
room today just makes it even well just
makes the world smaller and since we're
live-streaming I won't say any more
about that the slide that you see today
to begin our presentation is something
that one of our young people made this
year as we were in taize I had four
people who had been in my high school
youth group join me as adult chaperones
they complained that I have gotten soft
as I have aged however one of them spent
a great deal of time mesmerizing a lot
of our current teenagers in drawing this
particular item what you see is what you
get a lot of fascinating lines sort of
labyrinth een it is a maze and in it are
buried kind of wonderful words from the
songs that the kids sing at taize and
buried well within it you see over to
your right that little gold taize cross
which looks an awful lot like the dove
of pentecost desperately trying to shine
out in that way and it for me and for
all of the young people who attended
this trip represented what one of our
young people called that delightful
divine golden center that we all have
that gets buried in so much muck so the
purpose of this talk today and our time
together is really to think about the
ways in which we can through spiritual
habits peel off some of those layers and
reveal that golden goodness at the heart
of every young person and in fact at the
heart of every person I'd like to begin
with a prayer from West Africa this
comes from desmond tutu's african prayer
book let us pray lord we thank you that
our churches are like big families
Lord let your spirit of reconciliation
blow over all the earth let Christians
live your love Lord we praise you in
Europe's cathedrals in America's
offerings and in our African songs of
praise Lord we thank you that we have
brothers and sisters in all the world be
with them that make peace amen so
traveling with young people and spending
day after day an hour and after hour
with young people I too was younger once
i did not have gray hair once you learn
a lot about them and one of the things
that i have found and some of the people
who were in my colloquium session last
year of her part of this so i have found
that people today particularly our young
people but it's hard to define it just
to them simply don't know our story they
don't know the Christian story they
don't know the Bible it's very hard to
lift up these wonderful things and point
them in the right direction if they
simply don't see the story so I made it
my mission at Christ Church to make sure
they knew this story from the littlest
of the littles all the way to the
biggest of the bigs and what you see
there is a banner that was put up two
Christmases ago it's across the balcony
at Christ Church bronxville and it tells
the story of the Nativity we set aside
weeks literally weeks to tell the same
story in as many different ways as
possible to our younger generation in
the hopes that it would somehow seep in
that it would become their own and so
that's what we did this was the
culmination of it here you have Joseph
weren't they quite creative right we
just gave them the supplies and let them
run wild but we gave them an hour and a
half to do what it was they were going
to do to it so there's Joseph there's
the baby beautiful patchwork hey
underneath the baby there there's Mary
of course with her feathered headdress
there's the manger scene a little bit
close up and a star with pom-poms and
all its splendor leading the wise men on
their way there of course is a camel
lying down and
requisite donkey and sheep and shepherd
and there the wise men themselves but
things got a little bit different when
it came to the angel now this is a
pretty beautiful angel of course we're
trying to make sure they know the story
though so that we can build from this
story we let them run wild I was so
pleased with this by the way right like
a proud papa I walked down the hallway
where this artwyrd had where artwork had
taken place I looked at every single one
of these kind of just absolutely loving
what they had done until I got to this
one so I get to the angel and I look at
it and what you can't see right there is
that this angel got some extra friends
now I'm trying to figure out which of
the orders of the heavenly body are
represented here and I'm thinking you
know these kids ruined it they had the
characters they had this story we're
going to hang this thing up for
Christmas Eve I was going to show their
parents and now look at what some smart
aleck little kid and I bet it was a boy
did to this poster so I'm looking at it
and I'm thinking about it and suddenly
it dawns on me what those figures
actually are
the children in my Sunday school decided
that the nativity story just wasn't the
Nativity story without Angry Birds no
joke I followed up I made phone calls
that's exactly what they intended I did
my due diligence and the truth is
instead of getting upset about it well I
was upset about it but after I let that
go what I realized is they had done what
I had hoped and prayed that they would
do they took the Nativity story and made
it as contemporary just like it was
happening right now so if everybody else
came to see the baby Jesus why wouldn't
the angry birds they owned the story
they saw themselves in the story and
they worked very hard to do so it's a
lot about I used to be a history teacher
right history is someone else's story
memory is my story in the church world
we're all about memories were all about
remembering making it our own making it
personal but the truth is our little
ones and our big ones and especially our
teenagers struggle with the fact that it
is very hard to see themselves in any
story whatsoever they do not feel in
control of their own story they let
outside terms dictate who they are and
who they think they are and most of them
subscribe to what i would call false
images and idols some of them are
glittering images and some of them are
quite otherwise but this is what we see
time and time again so when we talk
about founding the spiritual habits for
our young people we're talking about
many things all at once and all of these
are going to lay over one another but
they need to know the story in order to
understand themselves
in order to relate in order to tap in
they need to know that we know that they
are buried in that sea of muck layer
upon layer of images and we need to
counter those things with the real the
whole the Holy I'm a big I'm a big guy
for rules when I was coaching girls
lacrosse there were two rules one boys
are stupid two girls are mean I figured
if they could embrace those two rules
nothing in life could possibly upset
them and we would win more games that
way but since I am no longer solely in
that line of work I have new rules and
these rules were handed down from my
grandparents to my parents to me these
are the bird family rules but these are
also the rules of our youth group you
ask anybody in our youth group they will
tell you these rules and they will tell
you why they have them every trip starts
with these rules most times we gather
begin with these rules and they are holy
rules rule number one know your
surroundings right this is really
helpful when you're traveling some place
like London and they have to look the
proper way in order not to be killed in
a crosswalk but it's really far beyond
that know your surroundings means stop
and take it all in we don't do ipads
ipods iphones they're checked at the
door when we meet they don't go with us
on trips they're allowed to have them at
night when they go to sleep because i
don't want to deal with their sleep
issues however the rest of the time
we're together it's relational and
relational means we are actually
together so know your surroundings stop
take it in
see who's around you see what God has in
store for you what gift has God given
you today and if we're walking in the
middle of somewhere I don't care if it's
a scavenger hunt in the middle of
Manhattan and I hold up finger number
one they will stop and they will look
and they will breathe know your
surroundings one of the best spiritual
habits that I've ever been given rule
number two it's not about you sometimes
they'll say yeah father bird it's about
you isn't it it's not about you how
great is that how much pressure does
that take off just knowing it's not
about you it's about God it's about
God's people it's about what God calls
us to do but it's it's not about you
love you to death but it's not about you
if we're in the middle of some
ridiculous hullabaloo right when drama
teenage drama shows up which it always
does number two it's not about you oh
that's right it's not about me number
three I just kind of new used to be
really wordy I had to pare it down so
this year we trotted out participate now
if you haven't caught on yet these three
rules are absolutely fundamentally about
relationship we practice relationship
with one another we diligently carefully
methodically set up the opportunity to
be in relationship with one another and
with people who differ from us so that
we can practice being in relationship
with ourselves and with God
so the three rules that govern the youth
group at Christchurch bronxville now
those three rules are really useful
they're really useful because in order
to get to spiritual habits we have to
break things apart and within order to
break things apart sometimes you need a
hammer and I don't like to wield the
rules as a hammer but they're pretty
effective in that way right it's a
kinder gentler sort of hammer but it
breaks situations apart and allows the
kids to step back and look at them and
embrace them for what they are it also
allows them to begin to articulate their
own story I think the next thing that I
think it's really important that we give
to these kids in addition to some rules
is we need to give them the promise the
promise that is intrinsic in our faith
the promise that began in the very first
chapter of the book of Genesis and
continues all the way through a promise
that their lives have meaning that God
loves them that they have been brought
in this to this world for a particular
reason and that living into that reason
is why they're here and why we are here
to help them figure that out they get
the promise that they are loved a
promise we have to prove to them over
and over and over again so that they
know they are lovable because most of
them will not believe so and if they can
receive the promise then they get the
next part which is the purpose okay
I'm a unique child of god I have
strengths I have weaknesses i have pros
i have cons but i am lovable i am loved
and if that's the truth then my life on
this planet has purpose and what will
that purpose be so we give them the
rules we instill in them in as many ways
as possible and i will bring this to the
concrete a little bit later we instill
in them the promise and we give them
direction to find our shared purpose and
also their individual purpose it's that
time of year in every youth group around
the country where our high school
seniors are trying to figure out where
they're going next oh the drama oh the
agita oh the agony if they realize that
their purpose is beyond college entrance
then this has a little bit more meaning
don't you think I mean I say that here
we are at Yale but I think where I want
to go next is it is an anecdote and it
comes from taize this year so one of the
things that we do every year is we try
to figure out what is the what is the
purpose our youth group like every other
kind of youth group spends a lot of time
and self-reflection and analysis right
we are not risk adverse happy to make a
monkey myself at any possible time as
long as it's sort of furthering the
cause and gathering more information and
so we balance our year we have a
pilgrimage a spiritual pilgrimage on one
end in February where we go to the
monastery at taize which is a total
luxury now i'll talk about taize a
little bit later and how the truths of
taize are
replicable here we have taize on one
side and we have a mission trip on the
other and they are exactly opposite each
other in the circle of the year one
feeds the other one informs the other
both are absolutely necessary in order
for us to do what we need to do and so
this year going into taize we shared
with the kids the focus of the week and
the focus of the week is the focus of
our parish in the season of Lent and
that is we're focusing on forgiveness
it's not a small topic right that's a
course and a half so I was struggling at
the monastery this year at taize the
kids meet three times a day for prayer
they have morning prayer they have
midday prayer they have evening prayer I
get about eight minutes of silence at
each one of those occasions and they do
a whole lot of singing so I'm letting
that monastery do a little bit of the
work that I need to do but you'd be
amazed how fast they forget it if you
don't maintain it right so they're in
church three times a day but just
because I'm that guy we have a fourth
service almost every day because you
just can't have enough liturgy can you
so we have a group Eucharist downstairs
in the crypt chapel it sounds far more
glamorous and gory than it actually is
but it does have a beautiful acoustic
and so we gather there and at these
Eucharist I sort of used the homily as
an opportunity to lay out what the theme
is for the weak and when we arrived at
taize I had no idea how to do this like
for the first time writer's block
whatever it was maybe too much time
spent on thinking about human resource
manuals at the parish something got in
the way and so I'm standing there in the
pottery place at the monastery taize
when it suddenly occurs to me what I
what I want to do so we get to our first
eucharist which was the second day in
and I pick up in the middle of a homily
this beautiful pitcher that one of the
brothers had made that I had just
purchased and I started talking about
how beautiful was how shiny and smooth
that exterior really was how just
perfect it was and I said well God's not
interested in our perfection and I threw
it up in the air and in that moment I
said a silent prayer that it would break
when it landed or I'd have to write a
whole new sermon right then and there
but I let that pitcher drop and it
shattered into many many many pieces and
I went on to talk to them about the fact
that it is often through our brokenness
that we come to God it is the great
mystery and majesty and wonder of
Christ's love for us that through our
brokenness we find our wholeness and
through our wholeness we can perhaps
encounter our holiness and the kids were
kind of dumbstruck it was dumb luck for
me that it worked so we went on to talk
about this and the fact that the broken
edges are the places that we should
probably spend some time thinking about
right that God comes to us through these
cracks
in the surface and that all this energy
around maintaining the surface just
isn't what God has in mind for us so
each one of those kids got a broken
piece that they had to carry with them
for the rest of the week at taize right
they gave me this piece I got the big
broken piece because according to them
i'm the most broken so I carried this
around as bizarre as that was for the
rest of the week and we thought about it
and we came to a couple of important
moments right one of those moments they
brought to me they said we really need
to embrace our brokenness don't we I
said well what does that mean one of the
kids have been carrying this around with
me for three days now said I'm carrying
my brokenness right this is a high
school kid I'm carrying my brokenness
but I really need to embrace my
brokenness I kind of need to spend some
time and figure out who I am and what my
rough edges are Wow
second thing that they came to me with
because they knew forgiveness was coming
was we have to own our brokenness if
we're ever going to really be able to
forgive because unless we own our own
brokenness we can't see it in another
person and if we can't see it in another
person we can't be in real relationship
and then what is forgiveness I preach to
homilies the kids preach the third
there's was infinitely better than mine
nine seniors standing up given 45
seconds each which meant about two and a
half three minutes I should know better
and yet I don't who preached beautifully
on the promise of Christ and the reality
they found in a broken piece of pottery
now what's going to happen next for them
and they all still have them although we
realized halfway through security that
we should probably put them in the
checked bags and not leave them on our
persons one of the things that going to
is going to happen for them next is
they're going to bring those pieces of
pottery to some randomly selected youth
group meeting and we're going to put
them all down and they're going to know
exactly where there's is and then
they're going to take somebody else's
and they're going to spend some time
with that know your surroundings it's
not about you participate we've been
given these amazing things our tradition
gives us such amazing things in our
story in addition to the promise and the
purpose it gives us the symbols that we
need to reach these kids deep down where
they need to be reached meeting them on
the surface does nobody any good it sort
of validates the surface our
responsibility is to find new and
imaginative ways to push and push and
push until they have to stop and look at
themselves just thinking about symbols
right the symbol
of light and darkness we have candles at
tays a candles burn all the time okay we
have this moment on every Saturday night
there where we remember the Easter Vigil
we remember the resurrection although
the funny thing about that particular
moment is that the Brothers of taize
have learned over the years that handing
a bunch of adolescence candles in their
church really may not be the smartest
thing they've ever done so they have had
specially created candles that burn out
after 20 minutes so it is beautiful in
there as the light spreads from the icon
of Christ the risen Christ out into the
room and then goes out in 20 minutes but
nevertheless we have this incredible
power this light and this idea that we
are carrying the light we at Christ
Church spend time every Holy Week
allowing the kids to design our Paschal
candle okay so we don't we don't mail
order it I mean we mail order the blank
one which is really hard to find by the
way these days but several weeks before
we get to Holy Week they have spent time
planning their design what are the
symbols that they wish to have on the
Paschal candle what do they want to see
how are they going to execute it you see
on this Paschal candle you have this
sort of lovely Pentecost e sort of cross
in the middle there right this is 2011's
you have an alpha and omega you have
this tree growing up at the bottom there
and for them this was sort of a
reference to vines and branches and the
tree of life and being rooted these are
all their words not mine up above you
have at as a cross and then above that
which we would all be hard-pressed to
kind of define for ourselves you have
the waters of creation the waters of
creation but it's theirs it's an icon
for them
they wrote it they prayed over it they
painted it it's theirs there they are in
our church at one of their evening
prayer services right they so want to be
together that there's a point when we
gather where they just leave their seats
and go sit together on the floor it's
not a comfortable floor but they
desperately need to be together and they
need to see that and feel that and bring
that light together here they are in the
crypt chapel and you see a raid on the
altar many of the things that they are
either receiving or they have kind of
purchased for others there are icons and
there are crosses right every one of
them depending on the years that they go
they get a different sort of cross or
talisman but they're all there and they
gather to sing a prayer over them to
bless them and then they hand them out
to each other these are the things
they've bought for their little brothers
and little sisters or older brothers and
sisters and parents and grandparents
that they are participating in blessing
in their kind of own unique very
adolescent but kind of beautifully deep
way here they are kind of serving at the
altar this is a very Christchurch moment
so if I was ever going to pretend to be
low church it's now out the door double
thurible is going there ladies and
gentlemen it's fire it's smoke its
symbol they're making it right they love
it they don't even care if it smells
good or bad right they just care that
they can see something right there
watching something go water this is my
favorite right you saw that they had
done the waters of creation on the top
of the Paschal candle we talked about
water all the time in the Contras
program obviously we spend a lot of time
focused on baptism we make holy water we
let them touch it smell it don't let
them taste it but we let them be around
holy things and think about what it
appears to be on the surface vs what's
really going on underneath which is a
little bit of their life story right
trying to peel back those layers and so
what happens is we get to these moments
here we're washing dishes after lunch at
taize it's really not fun at all I'll
they seem to be mildly happy about it
but some some chaperone and it's usually
not me we'll do something crazy like in
the middle of this when they're up to
their elbows in dishwater well yell how
about that baptism and they all kind of
stop and what starts to happen over time
because we do this constantly even with
the big Hobart the industrial dishwasher
back at the church right whoosh a
someone will always say how about that
baptism so they can't go near water and
not think about baptism okay we are
planting that symbol in them in as many
ways as possible to remind them of their
promise and their purpose and their
holiness and their wholeness this is
stone all right this is sagrada familia
this is the passion side it is the south
side of that extraordinary church
designed by antonio Goudy our kids we
were in barcelona before we went to the
monastery froze when they looked up at
this
this is Barcelona okay it's gouty but
there's new york there's stained glass
there are all sorts of wonderful moments
there's nature if we help them know
their surroundings they're going to see
it and it's going to shape them and
they're going to gain that spiritual
habit of looking around right beneath
this this is directly over the doorway
of the south side right beneath this is
a post and on that post is Christ being
whipped now the way the tour goes you
start on the north side the Nativity
right works out chronologically right
you're in the Nativity and you work all
the way through and the kids are kind of
blown away by this they're blown away by
this church where I don't believe I'm
not a hundred percent sure this is true
but I think it's mostly true at least no
two columns in that church are the same
size because each Bay is a different
size based on the load they have to bear
their different sizes and they're made
of different stones everyone is an
individual holding up the whole tell me
that doesn't preach so we came in
through the nativity side we're looking
at these columns they're thinking about
all of this they're kind of in their
heads now right they walk out this door
they walk right past Jesus being whipped
on a column and they turn around and
look at this and I said to them after
they had looked at this and we talked
through kind of the amazing bits and
pieces of this I said did you notice
what we walked by no so maybe we weren't
supposed to notice because it was to
teach us a lesson how easy it is to miss
our own sinfulness how easy it is to
miss opportunities to Ford
how easy it is to in the midst of even
something so great is this not stop and
know our surroundings the key to
building spiritual habits in young
people is making sure that we are
grabbing every single opportunity it's
training ourselves as much as it's
training them right it's looking in
advance at what you have in store and in
story and getting ready to see what they
notice and what they don't and rolling
with it that is not easy that's why I
admire what everyone who works with
young people is able to do because you
have to be on your game ahead of them
and they're used to taking in a million
different things all at once I not so
much but I do spend the time trying to
think about all of these things and how
perhaps I can engage them we'll see if
this actually
no male ego involved in this whatsoever
okay so talked about the story talked
about the rules talked about the symbols
that we all have at play but sooner or
later these kids have to take them in
and make them their own right we we will
constantly be barraging them in the most
kindly christian way possible with as
many positive images and senses of love
that they can have however we want them
to own it so what we did as we asked
them to reflect on what a rule of life
would look for them so they read the
rule of st. Benedict they read the rule
of the Society of st. John the
Evangelist they read the rule of the
Holy Cross monastery in westpark they
read the rule of the Brothers of taize
those are the ones i had laying around
my office they spent all of that time
and they were asked to decide could you
live by a rule no one said you had to
live by a rule could you write your own
rule they were stunned absolutely
stunned by that question
and the next thing that happened is they
began to do their homework and they
actually did produce a rule now their
first rule I will tell you had roughly
29 parts okay maybe we could make
something a little simpler well how
simple do you think it should be I said
well maybe less than 10 it's hard to
remember them all so they got back
together broke up into groups decided
that they could come up with three rules
three rules that they could definitely
do three rules that they could hold each
other accountable for three rules that I
and my staff and their parents would be
able to support them in living out their
first rule we pray that's a good start
says in addition to church services and
Episcopal youth community times of
prayer we set a time each day to spend a
moment in prayer they came up with ideas
for prayer they're all their ideas for
in the morning in the evening any time
they came up with their favorite t's a
song that to them would make them think
of prayer the kingdom of God is justice
and peace and joy in the Holy Spirit
come Lord and open in us right the gates
of your kingdom Scripture they opened
the Bible they went rooting around in it
they began to make that story their
story because of course it is our story
so they pray they share meals you can't
have a youth group without sharing meals
we have outlawed brownies by the way
because they're just impossible to get
off the floor so piece of practical
advice we share meals with each other on
monday nights the meals unites us and
remind us of all god's gifts of course
we are united by the social aspect of
meal time but perhaps even more
important is the fact that we are all
made equal in the act of sitting at the
same table and eating the same meal
similar to the meal line at taize we are
connected through a common experience
this is my favorite part in order to
stress the idea of unity at dinners we
will wander out of our comfort zones and
build connections with people we would
not otherwise interact with the youth
program at Christ Church bronzeville has
three parts we have the kids from
Christchurch bronxville who we regularly
see and who live sort of within the
bustling 1 square mile village of
bronxville New York we have the young
people who join us from our sister
parish mission san andres in yonkers
this is a spanish-speaking congregation
although those kids are absolutely
bilingual and then the third group we
have our kids who are part of our
after-school performing arts program
they are all part of the youth ministry
at the church and so we gather together
regularly which means they don't all
know each other particularly well
sometimes when we get together they will
get up and they will move and they will
find somebody that they don't know and
we don't have to say anything anymore
it's their role they wrote it they came
up with their scripture they came up
with their taize songs and the last we
serve others it's fairly
self-explanatory at the bottom because
we're live-streaming you'll note says
artwork for this document was taken from
the st. John's Bible and all the
copyright materials they're on so just
covering all of our tails in that moment
they went and found the artwork once a
year at the beginning of the year we
revisit the rule and then we don't
really revisit it again unless we
absolutely have to so we have created a
liturgy right because you can't have
enough liturgy and I will own that this
is rather unusual but they were part of
creating this service so our youth
program kind of runs from six through
12th grade right six through eighth or
one little compartment in 9th through
12th or another compartment but we do
come together and one of the things we
come together for is this service at the
beginning of October net I have all this
for you on the way out but I kind of
wanted you to look up here a little bit
from time to time so I didn't hand it
out I used to be a teacher this service
that we have which is sort of
recommissioning the youth group every
year and commissioning the confirmation
program the junior UIC starts with a
song and then it goes to the promises
the celebrant asks what do you seek and
they answer life in Christ it's great to
make them answer it's great to allow
them to answer but next follows is the
summary of the law right there is no
commandment greater than these do you
accept these Commandments they answer I
do do you promise to be regular and
attending the worship of God and in
receiving instruction I do will you open
your ears to hear the word of God in
your heart and mind to receive the Lord
Jesus I will with God's help the
sponsors will you who sponsor these
persons support them by prayer and
example and help them to grow in the
knowledge and love of God the sponsors
answer I will then there's a reading
then there's a song then there's a
homily and then there's this weird thing
I'm totally putting this out there folks
we were struggling to find a way to make
this real to a group of kids who are
relatively steeped in liturgy
all of our kids by the way whether we
come from liturgical traditions are not
are steeped in liturgy their whole lives
are not pros their poetry as Nathan
Mitchell says right they surround
themselves with their own soundtracks
they create their own dramas they're
rich in resources so we were struggling
to find a way to meet their rich
resources with ours to find a way that
was meaningful but totally out of their
comfort zone and frame of reference so
we decided to go relatively old school
and to bring out the oil of catechumens
now how often has that come up in a
sentence I mean you hardly ever here at
a general seminary and I can't imagine
how often it comes up here at Yale no
offense but it's just not a big deal for
us we have it we talk about it in our
various kind of ways I don't really care
whether you have oil for catechumens or
not what I care about is coming up with
creative ways so we bless the oil for
catechumens which by the way
historically would not have been used
for this purpose and then these kids
line up to be anointed with us oil that
their prayers help to consecrate and
this is what we say receive the sign of
the cross on your forehead and in your
heart in the name of the Father and of
the Son and of the Holy Spirit and all
those kids say on then they line up and
they are freaked out and then they are
so happy and so radiant and so excited
that we kind of met them where they were
they are freed in that moment through
the creative use of a traditional oil in
the life of the church
and once they've done that they real
they're anointed they circle back around
and they sign they're not on this
journey alone we are giving them
strength for the journey that's what we
do every time we gather for Holy
Eucharist on Sundays or whenever it is
we gather strength and nourishment for
the journey then they pray for the
people and we have started to allow them
to articulate their own prayers
spontaneously which well it's a risky
thing but a beautiful beautiful thing
when it works out and then they are
blessed and they go but there's
something about that liturgy which I
think gives them sorry I'm going to
pause that something else the last thing
that I want to do and then I want to
really kind of open this up and I
apologize that have gone on as I want to
talk about music nourishing nurturing
and nourishing the spiritual habits of
young people absolutely requires music
you might gather from looking at me that
I'm not particularly good with a guitar
right that is a safe bet my friends okay
it's just not me love it love people who
can do it can't do it my youth group
don't possess the skill but we will find
music and use music and trade music and
do whatever it takes to meet them where
they are because it's part of that thing
that gets them out of themselves right
you see everything we've talked about
has been paired with music they got up
it today in this last incarnation and
brother Maxime who is teaching bible
study decided that Americans should sing
they like to sing do you know how hard
it is for a group of Americans that come
up with something that's reflective of
America right we're the melting pot it
is the awkward moment that we all have
so brother Maxime decides at ten-thirty
in the morning that although our group
will not see one another again till
three o'clock at three o'clock the
Americans will sing something I'm always
up for a challenge so I turned it back
on the kids I was like what are we going
to sing and you know you can only sing
Katy Perry or Taylor Swift so many times
and I was kind of hoping we go for
something vaguely religious so one of
the kids came to me and said you know we
were in Barcelona and we stood in front
of the passion we saw the story of Jesus
isn't there a song about the story of
Jesus that we all kind of know or we've
heard and you know I was like will you
mean to him no not at him are you
kidding me I'm not gonna sing a hymn in
front of these people I said well what
do you mean he goes you know a story
like a story that maybe kids sing now or
people used to sing a long time ago and
in my head popped Sidney Poitier singing
with a bunch of German nuns in lilies of
the field right amen I don't know where
that came from it had to be the Holy
Spirit could have been the devil pretty
sure it was the Holy Spirit so I said
well how about this and they kind of
knew it we kind of know that so 10
minutes before we walked in at three
o'clock they started singing it now I
didn't know why we were going to sing
that so I let one of the kids talk about
it I have video of it but I didn't have
time to rip it for here she got up and
she said you know back in the US it's
februari this februari and it's black
history month and the United States is a
place that has historically kind of
brought together all sorts of people and
some people we've welcomed and some
people we've brought here forcibly and
that's part of our story and we own it
but we know that we learn a lot from
each other this is from a kid so what
we're going to do is we're going to sing
the story of Jesus as it comes to us and
then an african-american spiritual
and in the meantime the brother Maxine
was translating all right there was a
French translator and a polish
translator and a check translator all at
the same time and so the song was
introduced as a men and they translated
amen and the kids looked and they said
no amen brother kind of look he said did
it I did it amen so the kids started
singing two of the kids did the solos
next thing we know around the monastery
of 400 kids singing this song right they
have connected through a song some of
them didn't even know what the words
were but they knew this story they knew
the relationship they knew the spirit in
which it was shared right there's this
kind of beautiful beautiful beautiful
thing that only comes when we allow them
to be themselves and we use the
resources we have at our disposal so I
suppose as I wrap up I would just like
to say a few things and I've
deliberately kind of lap down some
things you have what you need you have
each other you have collective wisdom
but above all you actually have kids who
are starving for this in the places that
you serve the challenge right is the 20
seconds of heroism it takes to ask them
what they want and then to help define
it for them the challenge is to follow
the rules perhaps that I set out for my
kids that really are the rules for my
life to know my surroundings to know
it's not all about me and to participate
and then dare to be ridiculous dare to
be liturgical dare to find symbols
wherever they may be hiding dare to
raise them up and remind the kids of
them every single time so that the next
time you're standing at your sink at
your house washing your hands or doing
dishes you
think to yourself how about that baptism
that's a spiritual habit that's a
beautiful thing imagine what that will
do for someone for the rest of their
life quite frankly for the rest of ours
thank you all very much
I will take any and all questions we
have just a little bit of time
unfortunately i blathered on but i'm
happy to talk about any of my
experiences any other things that we've
tried you've seen broken pottery you've
seen waters of baptism you've seen
pascal candles you've seen liturgies or
heard about them I do have over here
which I would maybe some equip up my
slides are playing on their own what
that was was our after-school program
and so we had there they are just wants
to go just does well just make this
thing shut down there we go that'll
teach it so I have sort of reference
materials that I used kind of been
putting this together I have a copy of
our rule of life which is not
copyrighted by us so you can take it and
use it whatever you want just don't use
the artwork because it's from the st.
John's Bible and then i also have a copy
of that liturgy just for stuff there's
notes thank you that's great perfect su
questo sito yeah questions thoughts
comments criticisms yeah
more about your decision to play off of
that is absolutely on you know and what
I kind of wanted to sort of get to was
the fact that it doesn't require going
to taize to do these things for me it
opened a window I I will own my first
encounter with the monastery at as a was
through its music and and my having
heard its music sung by the way by Henri
Nouwen at a kind of directed meditation
in in the chapel the Good Shepherd to
general my first inclination having
heard Henry now in sync as a music was I
never wanted to hear it again that man
had many many many blessings but singing
not one of them I was given the
opportunity to dare to dream and take
kids somewhere and my boss indicated at
the time pushed me really hard to go to
taize so we went here was the thing we
sold taize by saying we're going to
Paris and then we're going to a
monastery right hey we're going to Paris
and there's a monastery at the end the
thing that got me right and the thing
that changed the way I looked at youth
ministry and particularly kind of
building the spirituality of young
people right we all have it and it kind
of let it out I'm the thing that shocked
me was we had these gorgeous days in
Paris we went to the monastery when we
came back not one of those kids mention
Paris they only talked about the
monastery so I thought here is something
that I need to learn from and I need to
investigate for me what it allowed was a
structure but the thing that they tell
you at taize right they hold a meeting
every time you go on Thursday and they
say how are you going to bring this home
because they're not interested in being
one trick ponies right they're
interested in transforming lives so the
first time I sat in one of those
meetings I felt guilty that I didn't
have a reentry plan
and so I thought if I have the ability
to take kids to this and have them
experience this how can I possibly build
from it honor their experience honor
that you know the guts that it took for
that monastery to transform itself in
the way that it did to be what it is
today and say we can support this and so
for that reason right silence right
we've heard other speakers talk about
this right unplugging right I talked
about Dee layering but one of the things
that I didn't get to talk about was
silence is essential when our kids
commit to pray in their rule of life
they're actually committing to silent
prayer they're not sitting in a room I
do love the Book of Common Prayer dearly
but they're not sitting in a room with a
book of common prayer they're sitting in
a room silently just letting go eight
minutes is what they said some of them
are way higher than that but it becomes
an anchor point the singing right look
if in my church on sunday mornings at
10am you'd be hard-pressed to hear us
sing at tays a chant lamb right doesn't
mean we don't have ties a evening prayer
or something like that however when I
need to work stuff out in goes the taizé
CD because there's something about it
that just frees you up right it is a
mantra that each one is it's a mantra
and the kids find that unbelievably good
even when they are butchering some song
that was written in check or polish
right German will never be the same
again after my kids are done singing it
but there's something about that that
frees them up and so for us it was an
anchor but it's really an anchor in
silence it's an anchor in space it's an
anchor in an ordered life set aside for
God's purpose and in order to do that we
need to give them the structure is that
yeah they don't have resources waiver
how do you take the once-a-week model
it's a great question that one of the
things that we do so for instance let's
take light and darkness right I've yet
to meet a teenager who number one isn't
fascinated with fire right I'm not
advocating arson but also a teenager who
isn't moved by some sort of music so
when we come together will tell
obviously every youth group meetings is
a little bit different but let's say
we're trying to get to the story right
these stories are compelling they don't
require Mel Gibson to dramatize them for
us right they are compelling when we
look at the Prophet Jeremiah who is
brought to the potter's house and the
you know the it goes all awry and God
builds it again right I these kids
understand exactly what's being said to
them and so sometimes just for fun cuz
kids need a break and life is hard I
give them clay let's build something
let's wreck it let's build it again now
let's stop and let's sit around this
candle let's just spend some quiet time
now tell me what you think now in order
to get there there has to be trust they
need to know that you're there for them
right as I always tell my kids I have
your back right and if they know that
then they're going to open up and then
they're going to trust you to do the
ridiculous things we spent that time you
know that exercise where the kids were
getting thrown through string I mirror I
should have they should have had crash
helmets on I do recognize that having
now watch the video
that's just trust games right but
there's something inherently Christian
about trust there's probably a biblical
story out there about trust and you
don't really have to sneak it in on them
right because they know that's dishonest
you just put it right out there
afterwards and they'll click in they may
not sing your praises right and applaud
but it'll carry as it goes and that's
that place that you'll come back and
you'll touch again a little bit later
I'm a big believer in our local youth
program in actually having a plan for a
year these are the goals that we really
want to reach these are the deep
theological truths we want these kids to
discover our weekly lesson plan may get
thrown out immediately upon seeing that
something awful has happened and these
kids are all jammed up but we always
know where we're trying to go now that's
hard but it makes the rest of it so much
easier when you're not constantly
anxious and worried and frenetic around
what's happening next trying to read all
their clues when you are embodying
centeredness right and security it
changes the tenor of the room
immediately and we've kind of all all
seen it and I am I am NOT my youth
minister right so that's not my primary
gig anymore my youth minister is the
polar opposite of me it's why she was a
great pick so my kids have two or three
or four or five or six different voices
that are all saying the same things
maybe one of those people looks like
them a little bit there sounds like them
or speaks to them a little more clearly
but they're getting all of that so it
doesn't really require taking them away
it requires I think a little bit of
invention and imagination and a whole
lot of risk right vulnerability is I
think
a great quality in a youth minister may
be the hardest yes your program you've
got a culture which is self-sustaining
but a former teacher to your coach the
second set up Alice it's going to break
it and you've got to have an addiction
plant isn't it ok what have the kid
refuses to participate in the culture
and if you consider aggressive some
stinking spots yeah absolutely some high
school effect does that was like yeah
right and and that's a sort of how you
deal with that yeah I think one of the
one of the things is you can't be in so
much of a hurry that you're you know
you're you're pushing something along
that's not ready to come building a
culture takes time I mean the culture
that skip has built in New Canaan the
culture that I built in New Canaan the
one in Christchurch bronxville they
didn't exist when we got there we're
talking about sort of years of work and
you know every once in while you look
into that class of kids who are just so
amazingly good that you can't believe
God blessed you with them and they seem
to reach out to everybody right but
there's patients so when it comes to
rural setting right know your
surroundings it's not about you
participate right participates the one
that's hard to say no like that's the
one you could say no to but they're
those rules are deliberately that way as
opposed to stand up when the teacher
enters the room or don't chew gum or
something like that you want to put them
on sort of a metaphysical level because
even in breaking them they're engaging
them the culture that you want to build
because those rules are about
relationship means that when those rules
are broken it is relationship that heals
them so the the youth minister does not
take that person aside and say you have
to participate in this that or the other
what happens is your senior leaders
who you have a let's say a deeper
relationship with over time because
you've been cultivating them and working
with them and who kind of understand
what's going on in a deeper way senior
leaders will be invited to go and invite
that person to participate without
saying you're not participating we need
you to come over here right it's the art
of invitation and I think those are how
that's how we navigate the sticky spots
we have kids who go through look any
time you you're vulnerable with kids
anytime you create a circumstance in
which they can rest or relax or let down
right in a place that always wants them
to build up walls any time you do that
you run the risk of a breakdown right a
kid who just suddenly can't handle it or
it's too much or whatever's going on out
there or happened on the bus or whatever
suddenly comes bubbling into that safe
place excuse me that you have created
and having the contingency plan where
it's all based on relationship they can
be embraced by the group without
sidetracking the group right rule number
two I'm that's a big part of it but it's
it's really instilling in your kids the
knowledge that they can make the
difference right I can be the jerk if
need be alright when that kids
ridiculous or a kid shows up you know
drunk or something like that at an ey c
event it requires an adult response in a
real clear fashion at least in my
opinion all right but a lot of the
healing and re inclusion takes place
because the kids have worked that out
right and leading them through that is
one of the greatest things we can do
does that answer okay yes sir
say it about how you introduce rule sure
absolutely how do you introduce rule
well if you're Michael bird you say hey
we're going to have some rules and they
laugh at you and then I will tell them a
story about how I got these rules from
my father who got them from his father
and how I see them play out in my 8 and
10 year olds lives and I will turn to
them and say I think this could change
everything for us so let's give it a
shot right it's an invitation but it's a
rule I always believed that story is a
great delivery mechanism it's a spoonful
of sugar yes
how do you actually give them to
brothels walls
what are they have a similar issue so
our after-school program is largely
african-american our friends from San
Andres who are regularly with us on our
trips and weekly meetings are largely
spanish-speaking and and then there's
bronxville which is largely neither of
those things that was subtle right
here's here's the I guess here's what I
would say we had this moment there's a
young woman from san andreas who was
with us for several years and she was
kind of very reserved and our kids
didn't know how to deal with that right
a lot of social cues are different and
she was reserved and they were reserved
in response and the set of the other and
you're in the middle of a meeting and
all of a sudden she says I need to say
something you know and as a person
leading a group you wonder if you want
to validate that desire to say something
but in this case we decided to take the
risk and she said I want to talk about
you Barbies well let's just go ahead and
lay it all out now shall we she said you
all have these coats that look the same
and you all wear these boots that look
the same and you did it to do and she
said so I didn't like you because
there's no room for me in your outfit
she called it she said but now I know
better you're better than your coat
you're better than your boots so why
aren't we talking
we create an atmosphere right certainly
of trust but of expectation dividing up
the lunch tables so to speak doesn't
necessarily get you where you want to go
right but I do believe kind of two
earlier points working with the
strongest kids you have the kids who are
most secure perhaps a little further
along in their faith journey maybe a
little just better sense of self and
allowing them to do some of that work
and giving them every single bit of
support they could possibly need in
order to do that kind of opens those
doors right this girl was one of our
leaders sort of by accident I nature of
the leadership position she had claimed
but because we kept the door open for
her constantly she saw a way to express
a real a real truth right not of these
false truths is the these kids make up
about each other it's difficult maybe
the hardest thing that we do one of the
sherry I didn't bring it one of the
bizarre things about this trip this last
trip was that a kid who was in my
confirmation class in New Canaan ended
up traveling around Europe it's a very
new canaan thing to do and he's between
graduating from michigan and going to
law school and so he ended up at a say
any Facebook messaged me and said hey
could I come to taize with you never got
to do this when I was when you were in
New Canaan could I so you know I'm just
expecting this you know little kid and
of course he's this kid he wrote the
most beautiful letter he left the day
before the rest of us did and he wrote
this letter and he said look I've spent
I spent six days with you I have no idea
how old you are I have no idea where you
go to school I have no idea of what
sport you play he said the reason why I
have no idea is you so ferociously love
one another that I can't tell the
difference
and he asked me to read that to them as
part of our final liturgy together boy
all right you want to hear that about
your youth group it has not always been
so and every year changes right new
group of kids come in old group of kids
head out but it's it's the thing we're
constantly after but I always rely on
the kids we set the tone but we empower
the kids to do the work anything else
thank you sir